là vous avez anaïs
la cépière
ça c'est martin
ça c'est d'un marin et joseph on
pourrait pas vivre sans on pourrait plus
détendu
alors sur notre voie de famille 18
fabrice depuis nomades 17 autres mais
dont deux sont au ciel j'en ai lu ses
talents grains sont aujourd'hui 94 et 92
ans en 1953 ils ont déjà une fille
lorsqu'ils apprennent la stérilité de
lucette
cet accident sera le point de départ de
leur famille hors norme alors que le
code civil interdit l'adoption aux
parents ayant déjà un enfant biologique
j'en ai lu cette finiront par en adopter
en 1960 la famille accueille françois un
enfant algérien de quatre mois confiés
par la dose danger
trois ans plus tard c'est benoît trois
mois qui leur est confiée
on reçoit quelques temps après
nous disons dans une chambre beyrouth
chez les soeurs j'ai quatre enfants dont
personne ne veut les enfants handicapés
est alors parmi ses quatre enfants il y
avait une petite fille donc libanaise
polio qui se laisser mourir
et instantanément en 1/8
ont peu près d'apt et les quatre on ne
peut pas cueillir les quêtes au moins
on va accueillir celle là
emmanuel est arrivé morio
moribonde
jeu de jambes paralysées
trônait dans tous les sens
affreux et alors eh bien à travers tous
ces gens qu'on a rencontrés pour
remettre le manuel sur pied si l'on peut
dire on a dégagé trois autres familles
pour sur angers et saumur mais sans
faire autre chose que ça si bien prendre
à fait adapté les autres autour de nous
y avait des amis qui me disais mais
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de
faire ça mais nous on n'a pas eu une
idée de la vie qui nous a menés souhaite
sur une route n'avait pas pas du tout
imaginé alors nous nous sommes retrouvés
en 64 avec en plus de notre mari cinq
enfants recueillis qui était
juridiquement adoptables mais que nous
n'avions pas le droit d'adopter et c'est
là que roger brunet le président des
familles adoptives française est venu
nous chercher nous c'est une réunion
pour le droit d'adopter pour bousculer
les pots de fleurs et nous aviez il faut
que vous rencontriez madame veil -le je
sais ce qu'elle porte dans son coeur et
donc elle nous reçoit dans son petit
bureau en cuir très accueillant mais
très très soft trading
nous lui donnons notre album j'étais
très bien faire mais marie et puis tous
les autres enfants et leur histoire et
nous voyons des larmes
sur le visage de la nouvelle se levant
venant vers nous et lui disant je n'ai
jamais vu un amour pareil
quelques mois plus tard la loi est voulu
et le président pompidou signe les cinq
dispense pour que j'en ai lu cette
puisse adopter les enfants qu'ils ont
recueillies et en 1975 la dass danger
leur accord de l'agrément pour devenir
oeuvre d'adoption
et dans la nuit du 31 décembre au 1er
janvier
mais apparaît une petit fils trisomique
la maman est un professeur le peuple a
est un ingénieur
mais comme on and on sait tout de suite
à la maman dès qu'on a vu la main que
c'était un enfant trisomique
elle a dit retirer l'enfant je ne veux
pas le voir elle ne sait même pas si
elle a donné vie à un garçon ou une
fille mais alors le peuple complètement
effondré le téléphone dans les premiers
jours de 76
en me disant
venez à notre secours notre foyer va
éclater cette petite unis al tur mal
fait on me dit qu'elle va vivre que
quelques semaines ou quelques mois je
suis tout seul à me battre venir mon
aide nous arrivons le lendemain l'heure
prévue un hôpital de la banlieue
parisienne force est en limite de paris
à levallois perret nous sommes reçus par
une jeune pédiatre qui nous dit m'a
écouté
oui on a une petite fille trisomique
le papa nous a dit
il l'a confié à l'adoption mais je vous
avoue j'ai jamais vu une adoption
ni rechercher un enfant trisomique et
puis vous savez dans quel état elle
peut-être que dans quelques jours on ne
sera plus là et on nous conduit tous les
trois le long d'un couloir derrière une
grande glace et dans un espèce de bacs
en plastique
un petit être verdâtre verdâtre et le
pop en pleurant nous dit c'est ça mais
ça
cette jeune pédiatre jia mais en plus
c'est un problème vous avez apporté des
habits parce que les parents quand ils
laissent leur enfant trisomique à
l'hôpital pour l'adoption quelquefois il
remporter le trousseau elle ne dépose sa
dépose la petite fille dans les bras de
mon épouse est à ce moment-là
précis à côté de nous dans ce couloir
d'hôpital il n'y avait pas encore
d'horloge électrique une grande horloge
qui sonne trois coups c'était le
vendredi saint
trond dit le premier enfant trisomique
nous a été mis dans les bras un vendredi
saint à 3 heures d'après midi si jésus
n'est pas dedans y est cela
j'avais joué dans les bras ou l'île en
une couverture puis je vous ai dit 'tu
ses petites fiches pas comment on va
faire tout les deux mais ce que je suis
je peux le dire c'est que je vais être
portée c'est sûr je vais je me batte
pour toi mais alors je t'en prie toi
aussi porte moi
beaucoup de la ram qui ont été versés et
y
beaucoup
là c'est la chance d'anaïs qu'est-ce qui
est toujours à la presse donc on a
toujours veillé avec son coeur à côté il
ya la chambre de joseph
et puis parisy vous avez pierre martin
et puis dans le côté il ya encore une
forme qui était la femme de minuit
on leur a fait une vie qui soit vraiment
une vie normale avec des heures de repas
des heures d'école des heures de jeu
serra s'était dit emmanuel doit suivre
le chemin comme les autres enfants parce
qu'elle est intelligente et doute donc
alors elles rentreront à l'école à trois
ans comme tout le monde le mont emmanuel
avec ses deux cannes y avait un quart
yard le souk losc que son casque et son
casque et ses deux fils deux at-elle aux
jambes je me disais je suis complètement
folle de léser s'étant pas comme ça il
faut que je fasse où je fasse pour elle
j'allais voir la m la jarne il ya de
très très souvent et qui me disait vous
savez je suis embêté parce que les
enfants on veut toucher à tous les
canapés à ses jambes alors je lui ai dit
écoute et laisser les enfants il faut
qu'il s'apprivoise avec cette petite
fille là et vous allez voir ça
marcherait lan nous a dit à la fin de
l'année soit laid je n'ai jamais une
classe aussi merveilleuse que il faut
dur sera rude l'humour
c'est une drôle de vie la devise petit
bouleversante lui tout ça je les ai
toujours avec les là
comme je suis encore aujourd'hui je
revis vraiment une histoire merveilleuse
et douloureuse d'un voix
le ciel n'est pas loin d'ici
jolène quelquefois sa maman étant ici
devant un bébé trisomique allait pas
bien du tout se disant qu'est-ce que je
peux faire qu'est-ce que je peux faire
une petite voix dans son oreille lui
disant moment ta sa tasse à 10 ans des
médicaments on a quelquefois dû peur
mais on n'a pas douté et on est certain
que que le que dieu existe et qu'on est
tous sur terre porté par le ciel
avec leur agrément j'en ai lu c'est
alain grains ont permis l'adoption de
plus de 2000 enfants un sur deux est
trisomique
800 sont des pupilles de l'état et la
plupart d'entre eux leur ont été confiés
avant d'être adoptée
pendant quelques années ici on a on
avait tout des nourrissons au tour on a
eu plein enfants parce que on a eu les
pistes réseau me killy qui séjourner ici
deux mois trois mois et avec des
nourrissons dans les alentours ça a été
quelque chose d'extraordinaire aussi à
vivre ça on me veux-tu un tour
quand opération et
une dizaine sont en réanimation et je
tenais ces petites planètes dans mes
mains et tout ça je
leur disais des choses et je chante et
je sentais que j'attendais de la vie
mais le ronron je ne l'auront meute des
draps blancs dans le corps de la rupture
at il révélé décédé c'est sûr que grand
comme ça il fallait aller acheter
chercher des fleurs pour une pluie de
fleurs
on était réussie parce que vous prenez
trop de place dans le silicium
douzy dont deux filles et deux filles
quant aux couleurs jaunes les parents
leur disais quand même pour ne pas les
laisser fabuler dans leur tête l'enfant
qui grandit on voulait absolument aussi
rejoindre ses parents là on n'a jamais
fait de différence avec les parents qui
qui lâchait les parents qui adoptaient
parce que si c'était deux pas de la
souffrance que la souffrance est
l'alsace au lyonnais samedi
18 ans 20 ans elle voulait savoir non
pas où ils sont mais comment il allait
le bureau veut pas le dire de toute
façon mais et qui a m'a dit à la fin
vous savez encore aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si on avait fait le bon si on a fait
le bon choix
actuellement débattue un projet de
réforme de l'adoption envisage la
suppression des oeuvres privées comme
celle de la famille alain grand c'était
avrillé un taquet qui portait le projet
à l'assemblée nationale
le vendredi le dernier jour au matin
il a quitté l'assemblée
pour nous téléphoner
en disant monsieur alain 20 ban am alive
1 ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est sur les oeuvres privées vont
disparaître mais vous on vous garde
parce qu'on a trop besoin de vous et
c'est vrai que tout ça sacrement s'armer
beaucoup et que on a ces temps ci de
plus en plus d'appels de service d'état
pour des petits dans les derniers jours
de décembre on a eu trois oui
et puis ça continue
dont ce petit prix celui qu en seine et
marne
fabriqué par deux parents congolais
en scène humains
abandonné
et
pour lequel on ne trouve une famille ce
matin
alors tamara
pierre martin ne pourrais pas vivre sans
on pourrait lui demander l'un d'eux
pierre qui à 37 ans 37 ans on se dit le
soir tous cas fière aujourd'hui pour
nous aider mais heureusement qu'il est
là c'est l'ultime haie dame habillée le
matin assez simple il nous dit tout en
nous chargeant par moments il nous
simplifie la vie notre amour
ne sera certainement pas aussi fort si
on n'avait pas vécu une fille comme ça
on l'a pas fait exprès vous voyez tout
ce qu'on vous dit mais mais
ça nous font l'un dans l'autre
enfin les limites physiques
sabrina wind os et ses cieux
mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça et
puis on voit bien que nos enfants le
juge très bien
et sur gentils sont tous gentils les
grands et des petits
on est très très entouré par tous nos
enfants
vivent